decide I can't help you nobody can until
you decide that you want it if you're
thinking of starting the business if
you're thinking of launching a new
product if you're thinking of hiring
somebody the best advice in the world
won't help you until you decide people
write to me all the time with questions
about starting a business and I love
helping you but the real problem is that
you haven't decided to be an
entrepreneur yet you're on the fence and
even if I give you the answer to your
question you won't do anything about it
because you haven't decided to be an
entrepreneur yet decide when you decide
the world opens up to you your brain
starts to find a way to make it happen
here's an example think about the last
car that you got once you bought it did
you start seeing it everywhere on the
streets it's not like they just suddenly
appeared they were always there your
brain just ignored them until you
decided the same thing happens in your
business if you're on the fence
nothing's going to happen when you
decide to do it you'll start finding
ways to make it happen it's the
difference between being a dreamer and a
doer dreamers dream you say one day
alone a business or in 10 years I hope
to retire or I wish I could lose 20
pounds doers do I've never had a 20 year
plan for myself if I want something I
start attacking it right now
entrepreneurs are doers no you don't
have to go all in if you're on the fence
this isn't about quitting your job when
going full time into your startup it's
okay to have a process it's okay for it
to take time if the goal is anything
worth doing then it won't be
accomplished in a week the big step here
isn't it how much time you spend on it
it's that you decided to do it and when
you decide you become a new person a
person on a mission that changes you
and what you do even if it's one small
action at a time there's no holding you
back once you decide believe